forest fires are among the most
prominent disaster risks
in europe
over the past years fires have ravaged
hundreds of forests
and destroyed many protected sites all
over europe
for 2021 the seasonal forecast is
worrying
with temperatures higher than average
and low
rainfall wildfire prevention and
preparedness are top
priorities for the european commission
eu guidelines on wildfire prevention
help us predict and prevent forest fires
and restore our valuable forests
a new forest strategy will make our
woods more resilient
and help us fight deforestation
wildfires
is an increasing threat to forests
forests which are home
to 80 of all known species
with the new eu guidelines we look at
how to make sure
that we build our resilience on a sound
planning
sound management and of course it would
be sufficiently
funded the european emergency response
coordination center
monitors 24 7 in europe and beyond
satellites from the copernicus programme
keep an eye on potential or ongoing
fires countries in need
get help through the eu civil protection
mechanism
and the rescue new firefighting fleet
[Music]
forest fires represent a significant
disaster
risk for the entire europe the forest
fire season starts
earlier and lasts longer the european
commission
has expanded its rescue capacity
we have to strengthen our activity in
the areas of prevention
preparedness as well as response to
forest fires